hey guys dr. Burke here in this video
we're going to talk about this so as the
P being silent it's a very large muscle
that connects the upper torso with the
bottom part of the legs okay so it
allows you to stay connected if you
didn't have that muscle you'd probably
be separated but it allows you to flex
your your knees up or your legs up so
it's a flexion it brings you forward
like this like view to do sit-ups and
come all the way up this is the main
muscle that allows you to do that okay
so it connects to these vertebra here
and it goes through the pelvis to the
inside of your femur or your upper leg
so it brings the leg up and it
stabilizes the pelvis so many people
have a problem with this muscle either
it's too tight or it's too weak or it
could be tight on this side and loose on
this side so I'm going to show you
exactly how to test it and what to do to
stretch it so you can get these
symmetrical I think it shows up as a big
problem for people because they sit all
day long or some people do a lot of
sit-ups but you don't reverse the flow
and do extensions with your back so if
you do too many sit-ups you're going to
mess this up and if you sit too much
you're going to mess it up and your
posture is going to be kind of like this
all the time so let's demonstrate how to
test this muscle okay so the first thing
we're going to test is we're going to
test if the so s is tight on this side
or this side and all we're going to do
is you need someone to do this so if
you're laying down you need someone to
measure keep this leg straight and raise
it as high as you can alright good put
it down good now do the same thing with
the other side okay good now you can see
that this leg went up a lot higher and I
always ask the person did you feel that
this went higher yes okay that was a yes
so what happens is that this side over
here is restricted it's tight so we have
a tight so as on this side okay so what
we're going to do is we're going to
stretch out we're going to have Lana's
back and stretch this out but this side
is good this sides not good so we want
to balance this this is going to
and imbalance with his pelvis and cause
hip pain or back pain in which also he
does have hip pain that's probably why
so let's go ahead and have you flip over
so I'm going to have you move close to
this side a little bit more good so now
we're going to do is we're going to keep
this leg straight okay and then we're
going to just we're going to stretch it
down like this okay so this is actually
pulling this thing down do you feel any
stretch right here yeah now keep this
leg straight and see if you can't yeah
right there do you feel more of a
stretch right there yes yeah so what's
happening we're actually without falling
off he's stretching this muscle because
it's connected right here and then
you'll bring it up a little bit and then
we'll just stretch it and we want to
stretch this all the way down like that
that's just one way you can do it in
many different ways okay so I'm going to
show you another way scoot back you can
take a foam roller and we can put this
roller kind of up right here yeah and we
can keep this knee up and bring this
thing down do you feel the stretch right
there so this is a good way to stretch
it but we're just stretching this now
would actually stretch this for about
two minutes what's going to happen it's
going to balance out the psoas
okay so you would if you had a problem
with the other psoas you would just do
the opposite so we're trying to just
stretch the one that is tight very very
simple no complications okay so now we
take this down now the next thing we're
going to do is we're going to check the
strength of the so s okay so the so s
brings the knee up here so it brings it
up right so there's a couple ways we can
do this what I like to do ii like to
bend this and hold this down resist me
I'm going to press down okay I'm going
to check the strength there that's
strong so this sides okay bend this one
right here resist
I did resist okay his right so as is
weak okay so if this sides weak then
what's going to happen is that he's
going to throw off the whole balance so
so again let me just kind of summarize
this we're checking the so s we're going
to press down and compare this side
because remember the so s brings the
knee up right and then we're going to
check this side there's nothing there
just you can relax okay yeah so we have
a week so I have sis now how do we make
it stronger now we could stretch it but
that doesn't work what we have to do is
we have to stimulate the other so s okay
so this is weak we're going to stimulate
the so as on the good side now it
attaches deep into the hip but we're not
going to press into a sip we're going to
press down in the abdomen on this side
okay so we're kind of working on the
soft tissue that attaches to the so S on
this vertebra so we're going to come
right into here and it's going to be a
little tender it is tender
so the two-step process we're going to
stimulate the the strong muscle it's on
the opposite side of the weak one
right through in here that's a good one
right there okay stimulate just a little
bit and now we're going to recheck the
muscle you resist it
see this drug actually amazed so it
instant got stronger so now the other
thing you could do is lay on your
stomach this leg right here this cell as
is weaker it was weaker okay so when you
eat when you lifted it so what we can do
as a step two is we could stimulate the
opposite muscle on the same side okay so
we can do the other so abs or the
opposite muscle but there's the option
action on the same side so if this so
lessons week we work on the muscle that
extends this because the psoas flexes so
extensors are all the glutes so we can
press on the glute muscle right through
and here and this will be tender too and
we stimulate the glute right there it's
going to make his so as strong on the
opposite on the same side though
okay good so now let's just go ahead and
evaluate keep this straight and raise it
for me okay see how high that came up
now the other one
beautiful now raise this one goes up
pretty high good now the other one okay
good now do you feel any restrictions
left in it right no there was a slight
increase on this side but this was a lot
better so it's something that we would
repeat over and over and over but that's
just an example of fixing the
flexibility issues and then fixing the
strength issues okay so go ahead and
apply this and put your comments below